hello and welcome to the 24th financial
charting tutorial with Python and
matplotlib where we left off we have
this wonderful looking chart we've got
the RSI added the MACD added and really
I mean functionality wise this chart is
done but it does need to be cleaned up a
little bit so that is what we're going
to be doing next is we're going to kind
of make it look a little bit better
maybe organize a few things different or
color a few things different to make it
easier to read so anyways let's go ahead
and get started with that so I'm gonna
close out of this this so I think what
we ought to do is just kind of go
through it one by one and just kind of
start at the top here so the first thing
that we do is this candlestick and let
me bring up a chart I my complaint is
that I think that the candlestick is
just a bit too bright so I want to dim
these down a little bit so we're gonna
change the hex color codes of those
first and I think let me grab the colors
here the first one I want to use is for
color up will be a 5 3 C 1 5 6 and color
down will be an F F actually I think
it's the same thing that they were using
yeah so actually we'll just stick with
that color down now let's look at the
chart now ya see that helps out a little
bit like the green was just too bright I
don't know you might disagree but that's
the first change I would like to make
the next change I would like to make
let's see we're good there the oh shoot
let me see here
yeah the next thing I would like to do
is let's change these colors here let's
put this one up here and then down here
we'll make this a 4 e e 6 FD
let's look at that now there we go a
little less in your face yep
so close out of that now the next thing
I want to do is I think we should prune
the upper why of ax1 do that next
why axe season to upper turn that air in
my syntax there's an error in lots of
times there we go so now it's not you
know just coming too close to the RSI
line okay close this let's continue
going down I think that was it with that
I think we're pretty good with the
legend
so the RSI now what I think would be
cool to do with the RSI is use the same
color as volume make this top line red
because I don't the note overbought make
the bottom line Green's that will denote
oversold and then we'll make the fill
color down here green fill color up here
red so that and let's so here we'll use
let's use a dimmer version actually of
that so one a 872 and then we're also
going to need a positive color and a
negative color
and our positive color will be 3 861 3
and our negative color will be 8f 20
down there and first let's go ahead and
take positive color and the 30 will be
our positive color and this will also be
positive color and I think we actually
need it over here to positive color then
we'll take our negative color and we
want that to be here and here and again
let's save that running it and see where
we're standing now awesome so we don't
really have any fill down here to really
compare it to that's maybe right there
but here you can see you know it filled
it as a red so ok so that's that I think
we'll leave the RSI there I still kind
of want to change the color of this line
but I don't really know what to change
it to so for now I think we'll leave
that and let's instead of having the RSI
here we could get rid of the RSI here
and add it up here so I think that's the
next thing we'll do we'll add some text
instead so instead of plot why label
instead what we can use is text so let's
add that here so axo dot text and in the
text we can use point 0 15 okay then
0.95 like right on the edge right so it
goes by zero and one it's kind like the
headspace in wit space maybe just kind
of guess around see what it looks like
so we'll say RSI and was just hard to
code the 14 in here because that's I'm
always gonna use 14 but if you ever
thought you might change it up you could
define a variable and then have it you
know benign dynamic if you want in so
that's what it's going to say VA like
where is it going to be
the color of the text W and then
transform ax o dot trans accidents so
now mmm it's just a way to add text
basically RSI 14 so it kind of it looks
more official I guess and it's just
easier I don't know I think it looks
better you can do whatever you want to
do though the next thing now that we've
done RSI we really just need to fix up
the MACD so I think I think I'll cut the
video here in the next video we'll be
talking about the MACD and there is one
more functionality that I'd like to add
so maybe in the next video we'll add
that functionality or maybe in the next
video after that pea how long we spend
fixing up the MACD so as always thanks
for watching thanks for your support
your subscriptions and until next time